kirk cousins and the vikings
get to four and five third straight
victory chris sims way to go with a
monday night football win over the
chicago bears are you back on the
bandwagon so is that what we're are we
officially stating that like i'm i'm
back hey what's up me and my son
officially are tandem now and we're back
on the vikings bandwagon i know he
didn't ditch them he has a little more
loyalty
but what you know you i just i don't
know where the hell you lie right now
i mailed in the annulment papers i don't
they've been so many issues with mail-in
items lately i'm not quite sure where
the annulment papers are let's just
leave it at that but uh anyway it's pft
live peacock
siriusxm 211 9am eastern hello to future
nbcsn audience and also even more future
uk and ireland crowd on sky sports nfl
and anyone listening on the podcast
the the vikings i
was impressed last night by the fact
that the run game even though dalvin
cook eventually had 96 yards
it wasn't clicking early
just like last year when they went to
soldier field right
kirk cousins unlike last year was able
to move the chains he didn't collapse
under the weight of the bears pass rush
and i think that's
credit to the vikings offensive line you
know the offensive line only gets
noticed when they play like crap the
offensive line played pretty well last
night because i didn't see khalil mack
in kirk cousin's face on a regular basis
no and you know i think the first thing
is what what you started off with there
the the run game and the fact that
they're able to stay patient with it and
continue
to just go ahead dalvin go ahead you
know and yeah it wasn't pretty or
anything like that but it helped them
manage the football game slow down that
pass rush you're talking about and then
uses the greatest weapon they have other
than dalvin cook which is that bootleg
play-action pass game off of their
dalvin cook runs and that's where we saw
kirk cousins make a number of plays last
night hey that's tough sledding you know
yeah he was happy last night of course
he was yeah i'm sure he was very aware
that he's 0-9 in monday night football i
mean he's a smart guy he understands
what's surrounding him as far as the
conversations is concerned and then
he's had issues with the bears as you've
mentioned and as we know the bears are
tough match up for the way the vikings
want to play football you know they can
stop the run as we saw last night and
make things hard which has made things
hard on kirk cousins because the pass
game's not there and all that uh and
it's not the most creative pass game in
the world so i'm happy for him i am it's
just another thing to shut people up
about you see how fickle it is though i
mean there he was he was playing pretty
good you know and there they were down
adam thielen drops a pass and it gets
intercepted by khalil mack and you know
you could lose a game because of that
play and then we'd go oh kirk cousins is
oh and 10. even though that wasn't his
fault and he played well that was all on
feelings yeah that was that was that was
a bad one that erased
the awesome catch that he made right for
the first touchdown of the night where
he he gets it with one arm
and flipped it in his hand to better
secure it one-handed while he was
falling to the ground it was an
unbelievably great catch that goes away
when you you
you don't secure the ball it pops up in
the air and khalil mack and and that was
that was when it was like okay that's it
all right it was you thought it was over
right there oh that was i thought i was
over at that point i thought that was it
that was that and if the bears had any
semblance of an offense it would have
been over
yeah well that's whoa okay do you want
to you want to go over there let's start
talking about that
let's let's put a pin in that for now
let's stick with the vikings offense
because
as i mentioned alvin cook ended up with
96 rushing yards on 30 carries 3.2
average per attempt he regained the nfl
rushing lead even though he's missed a
game and a half due to injury they were
patient
they they and and i think one of the
reasons they were patient with it is is
because of that bears offense we'll talk
about when the vikings were struggling
early the bears weren't able to do
anything about it and then when the
vikings got it going and then the other
moment that i thought it was over was
after the cordell patterson 104 yard
touchdown return to start the second
half i thought okay that was it it was
fun while it lasted but the vikings
didn't get desperate they they stayed
patient they converted some key third
downs they got themselves out of some
halls justin jefferson is awesome he had
eight catches for 135 yards last night
even though thielen had the touchdowns
justin jefferson is becoming
clearly the best rookie receiver
definitely and and again and moving up
the ranks of the best receivers
currently in the nfl i mean he's become
exactly i mean look he still has yet to
do the full stephan digs yeah but he's
body of work he's on his way he's been a
he's been a competent replacement he's a
lot better than
troy williamson replacing randy moss in
2005. i'll give him that he is
tremendously better than that
and and he's on his way to becoming
their top receiver yeah he's he's a
special player he can do everything
that's what that's what we see it's what
i loved about him coming out of lsu and
i think the thing that's probably
surprised me a little bit more than i
even expected is you know his
explosiveness after the catch you know i
think that's one thing that's caught me
off guard you know i knew he could 50 50
run rounds catch the ball over the
middle do those type of things but where
he is special and perfect for this
offense you know he's got a little ex
quarterback in his blood from high
school and his family and his brother
played quarterback at lsu so he's got
great feel for a lot of those bootleg
type plays you're to work the middle of
the field to be you know as they would
say quarterback friendly and what people
mean when they say that is a guy that
understands coverages and how to use his
body you know to make a catch or create
a little space to make it easier for the
quarterback to throw it he's uh very
polished that way and you know the the
word you kept you used there you know
the patience that to me was the key to
the game that could have very easily
gotten like
in the late second third quarter would
have gone you know what we're just not
gonna be able to run with dalvin cook
tonight it's not gonna happen we're
gonna have to just drop back and start
throwing it and then i think things
would have been an issue but the fact
that gary kubiak zimmer stayed with that
run knowing that oh it only takes one
with this guy and all of a sudden a
lackluster knight goes into a huge night
and he was close and had some penalties
and all that but still it gives their
team the best chance when they stay
patient with that run and it helps their
defense as we know is young and growing
and getting better right before our eyes
one thing i have to give kirk cousins
credit for too he didn't have
that periodic deer in the headlights
what do i do now demeanor he never has
the look but you can just tell by his
body language that if it doesn't start
off the way it was designed
he's very quickly on the edge of just
calling it a day taking a sack
just collapsing in the pocket we didn't
see a lot of that last time there was
one of those you know we like like we
saw rollouts where he had a guy in his
face and he still made the throw yes i i
can remember vividly occasions where
he's got a guy in his face and it all
breaks down he only got sacked one time
on the evening again it's credit to the
offensive line and i feel bad about this
because
offensive line gets ripped to shreds
when a guy gets sacked nine times when a
guy
manages to get sacked only once over the
course of an evening and be able to
operate the offense we're like praising
him
we we do need to credit the offensive
line but cousins i think stayed calm
they've done something to calm him down
when it's not
all coming easily i think that's what
was significant about last night's win
for the vikings
there's no middle ground for that
offense it's either everything works and
everything clicks and you're rolling up
yards either by running or passing
typically by running
and you you have enough to win the game
going away
or you get blown off the field
this grind it out be patient keep
chopping wood for three hours thing you
rarely see them do am i wrong no no
you're not because you know i think what
you're saying is usually when the run
game works it just goes whoa
everything's working here we go the
boots the play actions now even the drop
back pass game becomes more dangerous
and you're right they almost look
unstoppable to where you just go man
he's making decisions the way they're
running the ball you know those two
receivers the tight ends and it looks
great but
when the run is not there
that's when you and i sit there on a
sunday and go oh man oh they look crappy
watch out because it's just not an
offense and we heard this when gary
kubiak you know with peyton manning even
in the super bowl season there with the
denver broncos
you know that was the same type of story
when it comes to drop back pass game
it's just not the most creative stuff in
the world it is
predicated on their ability to run the
football and when they don't have that
they really struggle but cousins i think
like to your point too without the deer
in the headlights thing he's getting
he's very comfortable in the offense i
think he's very comfortable with
this is the way it's going to be this
year it's just not going to be pretty
always so we're going to run the ball we
might have some dull moments but i'm
just going to kind of hang in there
because this is the style of football
we're going to play and i think within
the comfort of that offense too mike you
know he got he's got the answers he's
got answers oh wait if they blitz i do
this if they play coverage i do this so
he's not sitting there patting the ball
sometimes like oh wait where am i
supposed to go with this one and he made
quick decisions last night got the ball
out of his hands and didn't make big
mistakes and that's how we've seen bears
upset teams that's why we saw mike
zimmer go crazy when they kicked it to
cordell patterson because he's going
their offense is never going to score on
me they're not going to score
so as long as we don't turn it over and
kick it to that guy we're going to win
the football game and that's where i
give cousins credit he understands the
full scope of what they're trying to
accomplish that way
yeah six offensive points last night for
the bears seven on special teams much
like their last monday night game where
they had three offensive points and
seven from their defense let's hear
from
matt nagy as we flip it over yeah to the
bear's abysmal offense and the vikings
impressive defense it was probably more
though
the bears offense than anything else
here's naggy on the offensive struggles
we struggled uh mightily on offense and
having the four three and outs
um
in the second half we had field position
we couldn't convert on that in in the
red zone um
and so i just you know it overshadows
how well i thought our defense played
and the different sudden changes that
they had how well our special teams
played i was proud of those guys so two
out of three parts right now are playing
well it took a little bit for me to get
used to but then i kind of felt
comfortable in that role and and was
feeling it then you get down kind of
into that fourth quarter when you know
it's it's 19 to 13 and you know we're
struggling a little bit with some of
those drives but that just comes down to
that trust right in this in this moment
and understanding and being able to help
as much as possible
like i said i didn't want to i did not
want to
make bill feel like i was on his
shoulder the whole game and i didn't do
that i i just went and played
and so it was different for me certainly
i'm sorry at some point my ass is on the
line as the head coach when it's three
and out three and out three and out
three and out in the second half i'm
saying hey bill i got it from here i i i
don't know why nagi didn't do that at
some point i think you've got to do that
because
nagi when it's time to go in and meet
with the boss
when you may or may not be fired after
the season
it's not a feather in your cap that you
let laser go down with the ship on
monday night football no no it
definitely is not it was not a good look
last night you know i i didn't expect
anything special certainly but i think
it was worse than what i expected that's
for sure you know first off bill laser
he's in a very tough spot let's just
let's mention that i mean it's week 10
in the nfl and hearing is oh yeah take
over the plays right he doesn't really
get to put his imprint on the offense
and maybe have things and and certain
plays that he wants to run that he gets
to install or just a certain attitude
about the offense that becomes the theme
of how he calls plays so that's really
tough you know second of all why do we
expect a lot of different results the
offensive line's still good not good
they can't run the ball and laser runs
the same offense as matt nagy that's my
issue with the whole thing anyways
there's no ideas there in chicago it's
all the same crappy idea getting thrown
around to each other with the guys that
run the same offense so you know there's
nothing there and then you know added on
to that last night you know what you saw
was we saw some different formations and
plays and things like that
but
certain formations and plays had no
answers especially for the blitz you
know and we just talked about kirk
cousins feels comfortable because he has
answers you saw a guy nick foles last
night in certain formations where mike
zimmer and company blitz them and he
didn't know what to do where to go with
the ball you know was there supposed to
be a was he supposed to be protected i
don't know but the offense is all over
the place i mean it really it was it's
an embarrassment hey hey chris if a
blitz is coming now i know sometimes you
can't anticipate it because it's
disguised yeah but the announcers made a
great point at at one juncture of the
second yeah i remember blitzed there
were no hot routes no hot rods i was
running a deeper out what are you
supposed to do if you're nick foley
that's what i mean and then that's for
for everybody out there listening and
watching or whatever that's what i mean
by answers you know there's certain
things i'll just put it in my own
my own terms here john gruden if we got
in a certain formation i had answers for
everything hey chris if they bring this
blitz i want you to check to this hey if
they bring this blitz we're going to
check to that hey if they bring that
blitz this guy's hot and we're going to
get the ball out of the hand here you
know and then if they do this real crazy
defense i want you to max protect and
we'll block everybody up and we'll just
try to take a one-on-one shot that to me
is a repetitive theme i see with the
chicago bears like they get caught off
guard with blitzes and pressure where
it's like
what we didn't even talk about this in
meetings they never blitzed this
formation what do we do and that to me
is inexcusable and of course that just
leads to horrible offense and really a
tough spot for nick foles and i hope
he's okay
well and you saw we'll talk about folsom
a second there's new report about his
injury and it's not a serious injury
which is good news
several occasions
especially in the second half when it
seemed to be rolling in minnesota's
direction with this collection of guys
that i i recognize the numbers but i
don't know who they are like 47 but
that's not joey brown or 93 that's not
john randall i don't know who a lot of
these guys are but 10 of them would be
up at the line of scrimmage anthony
harris the free safety would be yeah
covering the deep zone all by himself
and you never knew who would blitz and
who would drop it and i think that if
you if you put on film enough times
chris that you don't have quick answers
that nick foles isn't managing that you
know seeing what's coming and and
creating an answer for himself
then then you just confuse yeah and
that's what happened just confuse him
and and it all collapses before he can
figure out what the hell is going on it
is total
exposing of the protection scheme and
mike zimmer realizing
they don't
they don't know the rules at times or i
can expose their rules and get somebody
free every time and that's i mean he did
that you know a lot last night he didn't
always outnumber him with the blitz but
he found ways to go wait i'm rushing
five i know you have five or six
blockers but i've kind of tricked you
over here to where you have to block
these guys on the right oh one of them
dropped out and now you have a guy
wasted over there and you're one short
on the other side and he did that to
your point mike
like repeatedly last night the offense
is so bad in chicago right now i don't
know what to say i mean i really don't
it's as bad as i've seen i mean when you
talk about three of their last four
games the vikings the titans the rams
and i know they got the saints game in
there mixed in
and they made a play or two in that game
because the saints played too much man
but man other than that i mean there's
nothing
and i don't think it's going to improve
because of what they have there in the
coaching staff and of course the players
they have as well to go with it
and i think one reason why matt nagy
didn't take the reins during the game
this is an argument that it's not me
it's not me right it's not me calling
the plays it may be my offense and maybe
my team that stinks
but it's the problem isn't me calling
the place um mike zimmer
has to be happy with how his defense has
been performing in recent weeks after an
abysmal start to the season here he is
after last night's victory
they're starting to mature a little bit
and then you know obviously they're
getting a little bit of confidence now
um you know i think it's been three
games here last three games that we've
had you know other teams had the ball
with a chance to win the game and you
know we've been able to uh
to put the fire out i guess and so you
know the more times you do that the more
times that you
um you know you believe that you can do
it and then secondly you know i think
they're starting to understand the what
we're trying to do conceptually with the
calls and and things like that as well
late in the game it felt like the
vikings were still trying to blow it and
they had that fourth and five
with what was it like a minute or so
left they were able to bleed the clock
do you go for it there do you kick the
long field goal and risk the block that
gets returned for the touchdown and you
lose 20 to 19 with the extra point or do
you punt it's a no-brainer you punt
because you're suffocating the chicago
offense and on that first play where it
was almost an interception as nick foles
did everything he could to get rid of
the ball before he went down he went
down hard chris and he was carted off
nfl media is reporting no fracture in
the hip the hip is what they're focused
on it wasn't clear was it the shoulder
was it the back what did he hurt but he
was clearly
in agony and uh so far so good
uh for the diagnostic evaluations of
nick foles but but then they put tyler
bray in i didn't know tyler bray was
still in the league i know frankly right
and i don't think he did either based
upon how he played when he came in i
don't know what you can expect from a
guy who all of a sudden it's off with
the mask and on with the helmet after
you're getting ready to just you know
walk into the locker room and call it
another night in your stream
yeah yeah yeah so i you know
i guess it would have been fitting if
he'd have found a way to to crank up the
offense but that wasn't happening and
now we'll have to see when foles
will be able to come back
mitchell trubisky's got a shoulder
injury he's out yeah i can't imagine
they go with tyler bray this weekend but
who who else do you have what else can
you do that's right they might have to i
mean tyler bray was in kansas city with
matt nagy before this so he does have
good understanding of the offense he's
got talent too you know i watched him
down at the university he knows he knows
the worst offense in football extremely
well he's got that going forward he does
he's got that going for him he does so i
mean at least he'll know those type of
things but yeah i mean listen i don't
give a much of a fighting chance
certainly i don't care how good you are
it doesn't matter you know it just
doesn't matter you know it's another
great example hey nick foles is he's
solid quarterback you know but when you
have zero run when you have you know
maybe the worst offensive line in
football
the worst running attack in football
a starting running back on your roster
then i you know what do you expect to go
along with
really boring
non-innovative ideas in the past game i
just don't care who you are i mean you
could throw aaron rodgers or my homes in
chicago it ain't gonna look much
different it's not i mean yeah maybe
they make a play here and there but
that's a tough one and you know i think
the thing that's
bad about it too
is you know nick foles hey there's the
first play of the game he's trying to be
aggressive let's go let's start let's
get this thing going on offense
and he misses a big throw you know early
on to put his team in a hole right away
hey defense try to save me right away
you know that was an issue certainly to
get them off the start that way and
i'll say the other thing that didn't you
know help the offense necessarily the
kick return when you have that that's a
great thing but that's one less time on
the field and now the other team gets on
the field and all that so they have so
many issues it's not going to get fixed
there in chicago the offense needs to
just get the hell out of the way try to
kick a few field goals every game and
let the defense win it
the good news is they don't need a
quarterback this weekend because they
have that by one of the later buys the
bad news is they're going to lambeau
field sunday night football thanksgiving
weekend and
whoever it is whatever they do they
better come up with something better the
packers have been sluggish
in their home games early on so maybe
the bears have an opportunity to jump
out
early but
no one's going to expect there's going
to be another one of those nights chris
on football night in america it's going
to be g's across the board toriko's
going to take the bears and the bears
are gonna win that's probably what's
coming in
in 12 days the vikings though
four and five
three wins in a row and three home games
coming up boy in a normal year that
would be three automatic wins if you had
fans in the stands no fans in minnesota
for the balance of the season cowboys
panthers
jaguars are the next three
six combined wins for the next three
teams and look it's not like they're
going to blow people out but just chip
away chip away chip away and then the
next game after that is a trip to tampa
bay to take on tom brady and company but
the vikings could be seven and five
going into that game and very much alive
in the chase for the seventh seed in the
nfc so it's amazing remarkable turned it
around it is and look they had they had
the titans beaten
and blew it they had the seahawks beaten
and blew it you just flip one of those
yeah and you're five and four right and
uh it's a different world as you as you
hit the home stretch of the season but
you know that we talked about the
patriots being in this every week is a
playoff game mode the vikings are in
this every week is a playoff game mode
and you're building confidence and and
you know if that's how you ultimately
get your ticket to the party in january
you're so much better served you can't
engineer that you can't force it it
either happens or it doesn't and you
hate to have to live dangerously to get
there but that's what they have to do
and if they do make it to week 17 and
when the dust settles they have a spot
in the postseason field they will be
better off than if they had had it easy
the whole season because they've been
battle tested week in and week out to
get there one more thing about the bears
yeah
one thing i noticed late in the game i
almost feel like they decided coral
daryl patterson is the only one who
seems to have any ability and or give a
crap let's just keep giving it to him
did you notice that well yeah i mean i
think he he's one of the few guys their
schemes can't get anybody open they
can't do it
and there's two guys in their offense
that can do something without the scheme
you know alan robinson can win some
one-on-ones and he can win a jump ball
if they can throw the ball accurately to
him that way and then court darrell
patterson can make people miss and
outrun people and i think they just look
at that as hey he's our best weapon
let's get the ball in his hand somehow
some way but it just shows you yeah they
got issues all across that roster and
they don't even know how to use the
receiving core is not that bad
listen i think a lot of teams and
quarterbacks and football i could name a
few but go allen robinson anthony miller
mooney you know that tight end i'll
trade you but
but it doesn't matter the offense has no
idea how to utilize these guys and get
them open and make it quarterback
friendly or anything like that and uh
that's the frustrating thing about the
bears offense on a weekly basis
and i don't see it getting any better
and every year we see just like we see a
team get hot
and win and win and win and win when
their backs against the wall there's a
team that starts off
great
and it just disintegrates five and one
to five and five and they have 12 days
to figure out how to try to get a
victory to try to break that four game
losing streak when they face the green
bay packers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports